Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhasa
Než se dostaneme k tématu dokonalostí, chtěl bych tak nějak vyvážet, vyrovnat dvě věci,
Mluvil včera, když jsem mluvil o karmě.
Včera jsem u karmy zdůrazňoval význam karmy hlavně v procesu našeho osvobozování.
A teď bych to chtěl spíš navázat na dřívejší hovor o konu závislého vznikání.
Buddha zcela jasně říká, v tomto dva metry vysokém těle,
je dukkha a konec dukkhy.
A paměťte, dukkha je celá ta neuspokojová podstata našich životů.
Ale například, kdybych měl jen jedno příklad,
Tak například si vezmeme jeden příklad, kde se to zdá být velmi složité.
Jakmile se pokusíme uchopit celý pojem nebo koncept karmy, jak víte, Buddha mluvil o znovuzrození.
Co nás přináší do té konkrétní určité rodiny?
Je to naprostá náhoda nebo je tam nějaká spojitost?
podle výzkumu, který udělali lidé, kteří mají vzpomínky z minulých životů, tak se zdá, že se rodíme v takových skupinách.
Opakuje paně, se rodíme ve stejných rodinách, městech, vesnicích.
To by nás ani nemělo tak překvapovat, protože to, co nás přitahuje k jakémukoliv objektu, ať už lidskému nebo jinému, je ulpění.
Takže často naleznete v textech věty jako My jsme všichni byli matky, pány, syny a děti,
že jsme všichni byli matky, otci, sestrami, bratrami, jeden druhému.
Což pro někoho z nás nemusí být moc příjemná myšlenka.
Jo, ale je to tam.
Takže... Ano...
Celé učení karmy je poměrně velké a složité někdy.
Ale pokud se mě to týká, když se centřujeme na našem pravým objektivu,
když se zaměříme na náš true object, na náš pravý cíl, což je osvobodit se z duky, potom celá ta záležitost karmy centers upon how we create duka.
se soustředí na to, jak my vytváříme duku.
A jak dokážeme rozvinout štěstí.
Takže doufujeme, že teď ti, kdo jste tu poprvé,
Už máte nějakou představu, jak si odčinit nebo zrušit tu minulou podmíněnost.
Tím, že použijete tuto meditaci.
A jak začít vytvořit dobré srdce.
a jak začnete rozvíjet dobré srdce.
Tak dnes večer bych se chtěl soustředit na to, jak se přesuneme odsud do běžného denního života.
A můžeme se podívat na některé z těchto dokonalostí.
Dokonalost se překládá jako párami.
A párami v podstatě znamená druhý břeh.
Buda často používá obraz plavby z jednoho ostrova na druhý.
Což také znamená přeplavat oceán.
Nebo překonat bouře a tak podobně.
Tak mi dovolte přečíst těchto deset dokonalostí a pak některé z nich vybereme.
První je štědrost.
Pak je to morálka.
Střídmost.
Odmítavost.
Moudříkání.
Moudrost.
Energie.
Trpělivost.
Pravdivost.
Rozhodnost.
Milující laskavost.
A věrovnost.
Takže když se teď podíváme na kvalitu štědrosti, Bůh říká, že štědrost je nejsnažší rozvinout,
V tom smyslu, že nemusíte být ani dobrý.
Dokonce i zloděj může být štědrý.
Obzvláště s tím, co ukradl.
Proto máme tyhle legendy o Robin Hoodech a William Tellích.
Myslím si, že teď chci říct jednu prostřední věc, která se dělá na konci každého kursu, například, aby si dělal příspěvek.
Ano, nebo dát něco, objekt, dát objekt.
Takže první věc, kterou musím představit, je objekt.
Takže první se musím rozhodnout ohledně množství.
Tak dojdu k nějakému rozhodnutí a rozhodnu se, že dám tolik.
Zatím dáváním je mnoho různých typů důvodů.
které pak odstraňují, potlačují tu čistotu dávání.
Takže například můžeme dát jako dárek, ale jenom proto, že nám někdo jiný dal dárek.
Což je v podstatě business.
To neznamená, že by to bylo špatné.
Ve společnosti je mnoho takových vztahů, kde se vzájemně vyměňují dárky.
O Vánocích vy očekáváte flašku vína a oni očekávají taky flašku vína.
A je to společenská taková... A posiluje to společenské vazby a tak dále.
Ale vidíte, že tohleto není nečisté dávání.
Protože čisté dávání je dávání bez naděje na jakýkoliv...
Jako to, že něco dostávám zpět.
A vy víte, že lidé dokážou dávat věci proto, aby něco dostali.
A to je vlastně zlodějina.
A vlastně nezhoděj na to uplatkářství, tak by to bylo lepší říct.
V politice třeba, anebo v olympijském výboru.
To se patrně děje pořád.
Nechci být příliš cynický.
Ale nevím, kolik peněz daní šly do kapes tohoto třeba olimpijského výboru.
A doufujeme aspoň, že to za to stálo.
Takže můžeme dát pro různé výzvy.
Takže můžeme zdávat z různých důvodů.
Jeden z prospěšných důvodů, kdy dáváme, je, jaksi, když něco uděláme špatně, takže to tím
Žehlíme nebo nahradíme.
Ale my také chceme rozvinout umění čisté štědrosti.
A jak to můžeme udělat?
Tak já se rozhodnu dát nějaký příspěvek na charitu nebo tak nějak.
Takže já držím ten šek nebo ty peníze v ruce a já sobě tiše řeknu já toto mé bohatství dávám
pro prospěch těchto lidí a nebudu tak měl.
A já to říkám do té doby, než moje srdce je zcela pohlceno tím dáváním.
Když moje srdce opravdu chtějí dát pro největší záležitost, než pomoci někomu dalšímu.
Dokud moje srdce opravdu to chce dát z žádného jiného důvodu než pro to.
A když se to stane, tak tam rychle ty peníze do té krabice dám.
A důvodem je...
Když se vrátíme k tomu, jak vytváříme karmu, a víte, že je dobrá a špatná karma, všechno souvisí s naším záměrem.
Tento záměr, který musím dát,
Tento záměr, který mám, když dávám, čistý záměr, je nyní aktivní karmou v mé psychologii.
A když několik takových toho kroku učiním, čistě, začínám vytvářet podmiňování čistého dávání.
Potom, co jste dali a ten čin je dokončen, tak ten čin je dokončen.
To podmiňování je hotové.
Avšak objeví se hlas.
Dal jsi příliš mnoho, vezmi si to zpátky.
Jsi úžasný.
Ale vy si to označíte.
A, to je Mára, vidím tě.
Já jsem si to označil.
Já jsem neposiloval tvoje podmiňování.
A proč jsem se choval takto?
Čím víc budu takto konat, tím spíš zmizíš.
Takže se začíná vědět, že vědění, které se vytvoří kolem vědění, jsou staré vědění.
Takže vidíte, že to rozpoznání toho, že se myšlenky kolem nějaké činnosti objevují, je vlastně způsobeno starým podmiňováním.
Jakmile se potom začnete cítit provinění kvůli těmto myšlenkám, tak se potom začnete cítit provinění kvůli těmto myšlenkám.
Potom samozřejmě začíná nové podminování toho cítit se vinen.
A nakonec, abyste oslabili ten pocit viny,
Jestliže ten hlas vám řekl, byl jste lakomý a měl jste dát víc, tak se přistějte, že dáváte více peněz, abyste se necítil vinen.
Myslíte si, že jste štědrý, ale pouze poslujete vlastní pocit viny.
To je nebezpečný.
Můžete skončit psychicky nemocní tím, že budete štědrý.
Takže...
Další druh štědrosti je samozřejmě čas.
Dávat čas.
V způsobem služby.
Jinými slovy, chcete někomu udělat dobro.
Tak třeba přítel nebo někdo je nemocný.
Tak mu zavoláte a řeknete mu, že chcete navštívit.
A máte nějaký nápad, jak mu pomoct.
A ten nápad, který máte, je, že můžete
Napadne vás, že mu můžete třeba uvařit nějakou polívku.
Nebo přines nějaké jídlo nebo nápoj.
Ale nejdřív budete jaksi laskaví a zeptáte se ho.
Zavoláte mu a zeptáte se ho.
Tak přijdete k jeho domu nebo k jejich domu a uvidíte je.
A řeknete jim, že by jste pro ně chtěli něco jim uvařit, něco pro ně jim koupit.
A oni řeknou, no, tak až zas tak ne.
Kdyby jste mě určitě chtěli pomoci, můžete mi otevřít toalet?
Jestli mi opravdu chceš pomoct, tak umyj můj záchod.
A umyj z toho člověka.
Já jsem vám přišel něco koupit, něco uvařit a já nebudu přeci mít vás zatrcený záchod.
Tady máme ten soucit s egem.
Dávání s egem.
Tohle je další takový malý problém.
když člověk dává nebo něco pro někoho dělá, tak se cítíte dobře.
A to je ta zásluha.
Když obětujeme v buddhismu, dáváme naše zásluhy ostatním bytostem,
Večer, když recitujeme Milující laskavost, říkám, abyste si představili v mysli lidi a nabídli jim vaše zásluhy a požehnání.
Jestli to dokážeme nebo můžeme dělat, nevím.
Někteří lidé říkají, že nadálku nedokážeme ovlivnit jiné lidi.
Ale v praxi, kterou děláme
je rozvíjení štědrého srdce.
Když děláme dobré, tak cítíme dobré.
A měli bychom se cítit dobře.
Měli bychom být šťastní.
Buda řekl, že když učil, tak se cítil radostný, šťastný.
Když někdo přijal dhamu, řekl, že se cítil šťastný.
Říkal, že se cítil radostný.
A když někdo řekl, že odmítl dhamu, tak neměl žádné špatné pocity.
Když člověk není připraven, není prostě připraven.
Takže, když děláme dobré, cítíme dobré.
Že když činíme dobro, cítíme se dobře.
Měli bychom se cítit dobře.
Ale nebezpečí potom je, že činíme dobro, abychom se cítili dobře.
Angličtině říkáme, že to je dobročinění.
Tak nebudeš dobročinění.
Takže nebuďte, těžko se to dá přeloužit do těstí.
Tyto chyby, omyly můžeme překonat, že si naše záměry pro sebe vyjasníme.
I though we know there are other intentions,
I když víme, že tu jsou ještě jiné záměry, které vidíme jako neprospěšné, tak my zvolíme ten, kterým víme, že nás povede k zániku, ke konci utrpení.
A na něm učiníme naše rozhodnutí.
tento druh psychologie je se všemi těmi cnostmi, o kterých jsem mluvil.
Všechno, co máme jako virtu,
Ať už mluvíme o jakékoliv ctnosti, kterou máme, tak ta nás vždycky učiní šťastná.
Ctnosti a štěstí patří k sobě.
Tak to nám trošku ukazuje, jak můžeme rozvinout dokonalost dávání.
Tak mi dovolte přejít ke třetímu, a tou je odříkávání.
Protože to s tou štedrostí je ve vztahu.
Když dávám mé bohatství, tak to znamená, že to nemohu použít pro sebe.
Takže možná musím dát něco up, aby dát toto záležitosti.
Takže jsem třeba musel se ničeho zdát, abych mohl dát tento kurz.
Mohl jsem si třeba uvědomit, že kdybych dal příliš mnoho peněz,
tak bych si pak nemohl dovolit tu dovolenou, kterou jsem chtěl.
Musel bych si pak vzít prostě levnější dovolenou.
Takže jsem se zřekl dovolené, kterou jsem chtěl, abych mohl někomu jinému pomoct.
Taky se může stát, že někdo z členů rodiny je nemocný a já pro to, abych jim pomohl, nepojedu na dovolenou.
A odříkání buddhistickému učení
by nemělo být zaměňováno ze sebeumrtvování.
Tato slova mají podobný význam, ale můžeme jim dát rozdílné definice.
Víte, že Buddha sám praktikoval toto umrtvování.
On řekl, že jedl tak málo,
Měl jsi to zkusit?
Takže musel být velmi hlubiný.
Ale věc, která vzpomíná o tomto typu mortifikace,
ale chápání takového typu umrtvování, je to tak nějak jako, co je zlo, že zlem je tělo.
Když nejdu někam do blízkosti jídla,
a jím jenom nějaká semínka, potom samozřejmě nerozvinu chtivé nebo chamtivé chuti.
Takže já věřím, že důvod pro takové ty chtivé chuti je můj jazyk.
Ale my samozřejmě víme, že toto není příčinou těch chtivých chutí.
Chtivé chutí přicházejí ze špatného postoje v srdci.
Takže když pracujeme takovou mortifikaci,
že když praktikujeme umrtování, takže ještě přidáváme utrpení k tomu, co už máme.
Bezdůvodně.
Takže odříkání pro budhu bylo nahlednout, kde je ulpění.
A my nevíme o síle toho ulpění, dokud ten předmět nepustíme.
My víte, jak lpíte na své noze, dokud vám neodpadne.
My nevíme, jak lpíte na své noze,
nevíte, jak ulpíváte na své práci, dokud o ní nepřijdete.
Nevíte, jak ulpíváte na vaší rodině, dokud nezemře.
Nevíte, jak ulpíváte na penězích, dokud žádné nemáte.
Takže renunciace je
Tak odříkání je činit něco, abychom nahlédli to ulpění.
Jeden příklad, který jsem vám už dal, je, že nevíte, jak ulpíváte na televizi,
Dokud si před ní nesednete a nezapnete jí a necháte jí vypnutou.
Když jsme viděli to odmítání k tomu něco dát,
nebo odmítání nebo odpor věnovat náš čas někomu, tak tento odpor je měřítkem našeho ulpění.
Takže když dáváme, tak zároveň i odříkáme.
Ale můžeme také odříkat věci,
Ale také si můžeme odříkat něco, jenom abychom se zbavili návyků.
Nebo závislostí.
Mým návykem je čaj.
Já říkám lidem, že když nepiju čaj,
tak pak jsem už plně osvobozený.
Takže když vidíte, že jste k něčemu příliš ulpěli, tak dobrou praxí je nechat to chvilku být.
A to, co to vytváří, je všechno těšení o obsesion.
A co to vlastně vezme, je celá to napětí kolem obsese.
A to vede ke klidnému srdci.
Když si vezmeme takové ty běžné návyky, třeba kouření,
Kouření není jenom mentálním návykem, ale je i fyzickým návykem.
A pro lidi je velmi těžké projít tím peklem toho přestávání.
Někteří z lidí, který já znám, které byly schopní toho nechat,
Tak potom dostali, to bylo až potom, co měli infarkt.
Prostě potřebovali ten druh nakupnutí, aby toho nechali.
V tomto případě byl strach ze smrti větší než obses kouřit.
Myslím, že jeden z problémů je, že v naší sociálii nepracujeme vůbec renunciaci.
Že v naší společnosti odříkání prakticky nepraktikujeme.
Když řekneme v náboženstvích, že v křesťanství jsou půsty, nebo v křesťanství.
Řekněte, prosím, bylo to křesťanina?
Ne, bylo to křesťanina, ano.
Křesťanina má periodu lenti.
Křesťanina, když se podívá periodu lenti, může dát něco.
Lenti je jako fastování?
Ano, to je fastování.
Je to prostý období.
Masopust je taky půst, že jo?
Ne, ne, ne, masopust je taky půst, ale...
Takže křesťanství má také půst.
A muslimové kvíte mají ramadán.
Takže pro jedno měsíc nemůžou jít, když je větší.
Takže celý měsíc nemohou jíst, pokud je slunce na obloze.
Ve všech náboženstvích je poznatek, že lidské bytosti
vlastně upadají do chybného, špatného vztahu s tímto světem.
Oni si myslí, že tento svět jim přinese nebe.
Jeden z největších mýtů dnešní doby, že technologie vyléčí všechno.
Nakonec to konce nebude muset ani zemřít.
Se správným genetickým inženýrstvím.
Žádný problém s přírodními zdroji.
Protože technologie pro nás vytvoří energii.
A to je velký mítem dnešní doby.
A to nás vytvoří do disasteru.
A to je kvalita, kterou byste měli reflektovat.
A vidět, jestli čas od času dokážete praktikovat odříkání.
A když to děláte,
A když tak činíte, tak vždy ucítíte prospěch.
Například, když přijdete do buddhistického řádu, když přijdete do buddhistického řádu,
Buda svým nichům nařídil oholici hlavy.
Že já teď už nemusím ztrácet čas, abych si musel česat vlasy.
Ne, že bych teda toho měl moc na česání.
I přesto.
Takže máme všichni stejné rouby ve stejné barvě.
Jak si odstraní veškerá ranní nejistoty.
Měl bych si vzít něco modrého.
Čím více si odříkáte, tím jste v podstatě svobodnější.
Takže tyto dvě kvality štědrosti a odříkání jdou spolu.
a jeden vhled v našich třech charakteristikách ve třech vlastnostech Anicca Dukkha je kvalita Anicca, tedy pomíjivost.
Když myšlenka
pak můžeme začít chápat, zakoušet plněji to, co Buddha řekl.
Není nic v tomto světě, které je důležité vytvořit.
V tomto světě není nic, co by stálo za to, abychom to drželi.
Do čeho bychom se drželi?
Bohužel čas vypršel, ale já jsem byl schopný, já jsem mohl vysvětlit pouze dvě.
Ale aspoň vám to dalo nějakou představu, jak o těchto dokonalostech přemýšlet.
Máme nějakou cnost,
A pak je tu vždycky proti tomu nějaký nepřítel.
A potom jemná energie.
Například láska, tak nepřítel samozřejmě je nenávist.
Ne tedy energie, ale ten
Ten jemný nepřítel je ulpění.
Tak abychom naše záměry si uzřimili, když chceme dělat něco, co je cnostné, když se tam stáváte s cnostním,
že když zůstanete u toho chtění, pak zachytíte takové ty malé myšlenky.
Negativní myšlenky, že to nechcete dělat, různé druhé myšleny.
Jo, mě se nechce.
Zítra to udělám.
To není dobré pro tohoto člověka toto dělat, to je horobo.
Všechny tyto malé myšlenky se objeví.
A aby jsme toto učinili vědomím, to znamená, že to přestane ovlíněvat to, jak se chováme, takové to je doslova podvratné, takovým neznámým způsobem.
Jak už jsem řekl, můžete pro někoho něco dělat, ale oni vám nepoděkují.
A to vám tam zvoní léta.
Ale když jste udělali, co jste chtěli udělat,
tak jste to udělal úplně s čistým srdcem.
Ale oni by vám měli za to přesto poděkovat.
To je asi vše a během této přestávky chtěl byste chodili v klidu a moc to jaksi netlačili.
A jestli se objeví nějaké otázky ohledně toho, o čem jsme hovořili, tak je můžete tam do těch sklenic.
Děkuji.